[Music]
let's go
challenge your view lord one more time
where you're gonna lose your rating
you're gonna lose your rating
we'll see about that wait dolly
wrestling accepted oh we are playing
ellie russell destroy me oh my gosh
we're way over here is magnus okay now i
need to be i need to be serious okay
guys okay okay i gotta fight i gotta
focus
focus
he's focused i'm done he's focusing now
this is uh
wow i gotta sit more comfortably my my
hand on my mouse isn't very good
what could happen to anyone so that they
accepted
he
decided oh my god jack is going crazy
okay okay i gotta fully concentrate yeah
i'm not saying anything
okay we're doing it right after guys
we're doing it right after
three thousand
we jumped 500 people right now
yeah we're gonna pick we'll play some
more don't worry
guys we're coming forward we'll calm
down i literally did not do anything
calm down people the boys are gonna buy
you all
you know i have the power
wow
wow
can you imagine magnus might be watching
right now okay okay i gotta go focus
yeah
okay they don't
see you all the time but that's okay
this is the board
wow
he's coming until
it's 2 am oh my gosh i think this is the
best preparation for the commentary i
definitely think so
the best prep for
i'm literally playing somebody who's in
the candidates yeah crazy yes i can't
believe it neither can i okay okay we're
concentrating
wow
my friend my friend it's a drawer
oh you flagged him did i win that night
yeah i mean
he was he was zero on time
then you might need some help
okay you don't really see your clock so
you might be after they don't see my
clock not all of this but okay i'll i'll
resize it yeah
that's the next game
okay
okay
uh
okay
hit him
what's going on
[Music]
okay we need to fix the clock
a bit
okay we got the clock
the clock is fixed
everybody relax
uh
ah we see there's a complete quit on my
chest yeah i mean
he's having he's been reborn by
bishop
a
um
[Music]
look at you that was beautiful all right
until the end yay
never resign
you're 68 to 62. no but that's like i i
understand
it's two
two
okay
[Music]
jeff is going crazy
[Music]
oh someone's gonna get naked
[Music]
wow
come on come on
couple more we won't play too long yeah
just a couple more just a couple more
i mean i think anniversary is the one
who needs to to go to bada what do you
think yeah
do
definitely
think he's like we will we will exchange
a smile tomorrow
i'll come up to him before the game
with your nice cute smile
is called bishops ladies and gentlemen
we fight
we fight oh there is rookie for you
no people mess them up here
rebecca
black harris
wow let's go
30 second chest you met cute smile dania
yeah
natural smile but imagine if you
didn't really get stilted because of you
he's going to get so well he's already
pretty tilted
the fact that he's playing 30 second
chess
means he's guilty
oh yeah because you were attacking
where's the penguin when you need
oh this was our nice
spine
[Music]
like before
please
[Music]
is he's he's doing better he's easy i
mean we usually are about evenly matched
in 30 seconds before he retired
before he retired yeah
are you allowed to play
oh
[Music]
it's growing
he's improving
my residency
well from you know
from the other side if he wins the match
i'll give him some confidence so i'm
actually doing this deliberately exactly
that's exactly what i meant
[Music]
yeah and then he will join the studio
for the interview
i i should ask him tomorrow i'll be
taking his interview and i should ask
him like
was playing online lucas you're against
uh one of our commentators then you'll
never do anything
he's insanely strong it's actually
pretty crazy
he just became strong right now
no he is always
maybe you need to to make your you know
cosplay clothes for winter
with all this fruit here we go this is
very happy
[Music]
exactly
exceptional
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh this speed is amazing
the old russian school
exactly
the old russian school congratulations
dania sensei
congratulations
guys ladies and gentlemen we're in
madrid at the candidates queen just like
queen isabella before before
just like quenzel before we're here all
about
leading the legacy legacy of the one who
is the legend on leeches
the legacy of the person who is the
legend on leeches
mother
i wasn't
forgot about them
believe
so ladies and gentlemen for those of you
who don't know we're in madrid
and we're
commentating the candidates i mean dan
is commentating the candidates and right
now danny is playing
the one and only what
are from the candidates himself
beautiful
[Music]
ah
bravo
can i go e5
uh
trying the old fisher bandco
yeah the rest is preparing for his
opponent right
who is he playing
can you guys check whatever is playing
tomorrow
i think
nepo
oh my god he's doing this d lord my
youness thank you so much for five subs
alirez is playing napo tomorrow
wow
oh my gosh
show him some
um
some examples of rook and games
i actually like this
yes oh my gosh
that's so good 30 second chest
he does the same we both we both do that
yeah he wouldn't like it any other way
yeah you would like if you were kind to
him
i'm not talking to anybody we're playing
30 second chest here yeah
that's like people in life you shouldn't
be kind to them because
now he's mad
wow
beautiful brook
just played an amazing game
amazing 30 seconds
yeah actually
no joke
[Music]
come
just a little bit
we're close you're close
you're very close
what a game that was a nice game
and i just wanted everything
because you don't put your your
concentrating pose
[Music]
yeah
no
oh god
where's the mate though
oh no
oh no
wait he what did he win i got made
oh queen f1 me it's true
it was beautiful
we're the candidates
it's all about leading the legacy wow he
always trades playing sessions
interesting he's beautiful but he's not
it
he likes to attack right
well he likes both he's a classic player
really player but he likes reading
queens
here we go
[Music]
you need to put your your your
concentrated you know
always scream trace imagine if he was
playing magnus right before you no no he
was not he was not
he was playing somebody when he was game
i don't think so
no
i'm like well you need candidates to
play minecraft
oh what a beautiful night oh you
sacrificed you can easily well
whatever dina
says oh my god he takes the rook
[Music]
yes
wow
yes whoa
beautiful my headset that was so
that's fine
oh my god that wasn't that crazy
that was so beautiful
oh my gosh it's so amazing oh he blunted
his rook and i didn't take it ah
i didn't even notice that he did that
guys the bench on here is so high
where the candidates
should be able to win this yeah
i didn't think it would do that
it's completely winning it's okay it's
okay don't worry sensei dania
you're fine you're good i'm gonna win
you're gonna win anyway
right guys three thousand people
watching
don't worry i'll be fine oh my god what
am i doing
i'm just free moving way too much it's
still okay
openly called bishops i need to get my
thing out of that yeah it's getting
beautiful
i mean you you don't know i'm playing
faster i just need to be yeah more
you're going to
you don't increase
wow
yes you won you saw it down by two
though amazing oh he's tilting
he's still thinking
[Music]
all right last few
and there's this legend from smashing 30
seconds need candidates
what was that
congratulations okay last uh last three
to 25 games
i'll tell him to go to sleep afterwards
yeah
he's gonna go something burn into your
how do you think
uh playing versus bullet on super bowl
yeah helps you against nepo yeah we win
against watch him beat nepo tomorrow
that would be yeah he's gonna he's gonna
beat
dania giving lessons to to to young boys
on what time they need to go to sleep
isn't that that's very ironic isn't it
yeah isn't that
cute but now he's
nicola how are you doing
what's up
look where we are surprised
[Music]
no no tell him to go to sleep
no no no
then you gotta sleep last year then you
gotta sleep
that's cute
dania giving less life lessons to us
tilted he's
annoyed too
do you think his family knows what he's
doing right now that's exactly what i'm
wondering it's like
does his father know about this yeah i
mean i didn't dare to ask it on your
stream because i don't know how how
kindly oh wow how kind you want to be or
you don't want to be
do you think his brother knows what he's
saying
maybe he's just he has insomnia and he's
right he's but but then he needs to be
everyone is sleeping and he's oh no you
two there was a dummy that was not me
but there was a fourth no
[Music]
don't repeat
oh beautiful
beautiful bravo
wow that's so beautiful
sorry accidentally uh i've got to go i
said i am and say go sleep
good
tell him to go to sleep
good luck tomorrow versus nepo
all right
that was a really fun match wow yeah i'm
honored that i was helping loressa
prepare i don't believe that you were
the one who stops this match
i honestly don't have an amazing level
of discipline no that's i mean i really
i really i don't recognize you
like you are the one who stops the match
how's that how's that i don't believe my
eyes
i know it's crazy
you know thanks for making a bubbly
guest appearance yeah fantastic
commentary of the fantastic match i
still uh
cannot believe my eyes you farmed uh one
of the candidates that's very impressive
danny congratulations it got better as
the stream went on yeah
no first you first you farmed world
champion mvl and then you farmed the
future world champion
that's exactly what i did yeah
but that's a detail
unstoppable all right commentary
tomorrow folks thanks everybody great
stream yay see y'all later peace bye
[Music]